couch warriors I'm the life of the party
I'm the guy who starts a dance circle
and then points that shy people and
forces them into the center they love it
but now there's one party that me and
every other man aren't invited to and
it's on an island there's an
entrepreneur her name is Christina Roth
who's created this super she island an
exclusive getaway destination located
off the coast of Finland oh that is
available only for women her aim is for
women to vacation at a destination away
from society's pressures and embrace an
all-female energy I embrace that I'm
gonna go on vacation to this island just
so you can't come he would last for one
day Oh
boom he just Matz played vacation to you
come on ladies we gave you a whole
ghostbusters and now you take an island
I want to look closely at this look at
this lady Rock the goal of the island is
to connect women of all ages in
networking group uniting female
powerhouses no men are allowed I can't
wait for you guys to see what we created
for you
you guys know
lady you can wait you banned us I
haven't been this persecuted since White
Castle started requiring a key code to
open the bathroom and in situations like
that every second counts
look there's no place I want to be more
than where you tell me I can't go and I
can't go to this island this is a
nightmare
to expose the horror of gender-specific
living I sent citizen journalists Nicole
Thurman and Laura Grey to super she
island Nicole Laura how terrible is it
there Oh
oh yeah it's awful I can barely hear you
over all these shrill lady voices
melodic puffins and semi competitive
beach volleyball games yes well where's
Nicole was she a lady nap by radical
feminists hey girl here's your acai
mojito I mean the evil kool-aid they're
forcing us to drink it's probably full
of male tears and Gloria Steinem sweat
and definitely top-shelf Ron this is a
really good run
this place is hell Jordan I haven't had
one second alone this female network
executive has been constantly harassing
me about hosting my own show and the
awkward part is she looks me in the eyes
the whole time I'm like Hello I'm down
here
she even let me finish a sentence
today which is exhausting that sounds
like hell Laura but you know what two
can play at this game let's take a look
at my newly established meadow Leigh
Island it's called the Isle of Man
trademark pending check it with cobia
Tim and the other bros we set out there
guys it's been four hours Jesus so how's
it going it's awful Jordan it's amazing
Jordan within minutes of arriving we
were asserting dominance by punching
each other in the throats and bragging
about who has the most shirts from
bonobos its descended into chaos its
ascended into chaos this is men at our
best I fought off 12 guys for the remote
control and I made this crown from their
bones we don't even have TV here Jordan
we're just competing over everything
pride honour water what would you guys
did you run out of water oh no no
there's more than enough it's just we
felt really important to claim what was
ours first it's a bone crown okay we
have to go Jordan a boulder fight is
about to begin
it's not what you think Jordan sounds
like a fight with boulders okay it's
exactly what you think that could be a
lawsuit
it could be Nicola are you okay Oh how
did the catfight start you all right
what no I just got all the seed money
for the app I'm developing
it was wild it was so wild I went to
this grouse women's unity circle and I
think I blacked out but when I woke up I
had a coherent business plan this is the
worst yesterday a woman held me while I
cried and taught me about something
called gender dynamics in the workplace
real snowflake talk but the way these
women explained it I think we need to
have a conversation when I get back
Oh God dude guys guys are you still
there Kobe Kobe cup wit where where's
Tim I don't to put too fine a point on
this Jordan I murdered Tim what's but
murder it's a word that means to
intentionally kill I intentionally
killed them no I know the definition I
mean what happened I used to hammer
Jordan it was easier than I expected
emotionally I mean I felt like I've been
conditioned to believe that there's
something inherently masculine about
violence and that my worth is a man is
determined by my ability to dominate
others I'm still was that Tim I have to
go I have something to take care of the
whoa what was that said something is
murdering a hand oh no no whoa whoa whoa
[Applause]
Josh and Arin you're on the Isle of Man
well kind of we're on Fire Island yeah
it's an island of men Oh fun glyco oh
god no Jordan we've had our own special
man only island for decades to escape
from straight men that's that's actually
not fair
[Applause]
[Music]